c'est luut pistache oh mon loulou il est
trop bien ce Chevreux je l'aime
trop viens par
là
pistache moi mon travail c'est de rendre
heureux tous les animaux surtout les
animaux maltraités ça a fait une vie
dans le quartier en fait par exemple les
gens ça les apaise ils sont super
contents d'avoir ça que des voitures
brûlées en bas de chez
eux Delphine Valentine venez par là
doucement doucement mon loulou
je peux pas sauver toute la terre faut
déjà rendre heureux cela et en fait je
pense encore en sauver ce serait pas les
[Musique]
seuls en fait moi je suis un lycéen un
berger
[Musique]
lycéen salut c'est leilla de brut et
aujourd'hui je me trouve à vill le belle
pour vous parler d'un jeune garçon qui a
18 ans il s'appelle EMR em lui en fait
ce qu'il a fait c'est qu'il a a mis en
place une ferme juste devant là où il
habite pour faire en profiter les
habitants mais aussi parce que lui il
adore les animaux et donc aujourd'hui on
va un petit peu découvrir son monde àer
donc là on est en train de regarder ben
mes animaux je suis en train de regarder
l'âne les chèvres et les moutons
pistache viens là c'est qui pistache
c'est le tout petit chevreau qui est
caché entre les deux barrières là-bas ça
fait combien de temps que tu les as tous
ces animaux toi l' ça fait 4 mois les
chèvres ça fait un an les moutons 1 an
et demi la plus vieille breie elle un an
et
demi cette poule elle est venue
hier c'est c'est une poule de race
coucou de reen c'est quelqu'un qui nous
l'a ramené comment il a accueilli sa
nouvelle voisine sa nouvelle copine
plutôt ouais nouvelle COP il acccueille
très bien là il fait que de surveiller
si les autres coqus ne tournent pas
autour c'est lui pistache oh mon loulou
Delphine Valentine venez par là venez
par là avant qu'ils arrivent ici les
animaux tu tu faisais quoi toi tes
journées comment tu t'occupais avant ben
j'étais dans mon dans mon autre ferme à
l'autre bout de la ville c'est Alan
Sartori chef de projet de la mairie
référent développement durable qui m'a
qui m'a projeté moi j'étais grave pour
en fait au début j'avais je craignais un
peu je disais ah non c'est dans une cité
tout ça après je me suis dit si je
surveille il y a rien qui va se passer
oh qu'est-ce que tu fais donc là je vais
vous présenter Oreo c'est un anâne du
côteentin de la Croix Saint-André lui en
fait j'avais trouvé sur le bon coin j'ai
créé un lien avec le monsieur il me l'a
vendu alors comment on fait en fait on
fait ça comme ça
ok imaginer un jour te retrouverver à
t'occuper d'unan en face de de ton
quartier non pas trop viens là là on va
dans la forêt du montriffard le quartier
il a quand même un côté nature c'est
proche de la nature on est super proche
de la nature par exemple le matin
parfois quand je mange je fais mon petit
déjeuner parfois avec les animaux ben je
vois des écurilles qui passent devant
moi ça fait super plaisir allez on y
va allez Oreo vas-y s'il te plaît là
arrête de faire bon ben on va pas partir
si tu marches pas façon on est très
proche du quartier on très proche des
des voitures ça peut être aussi pollué
et cetera que c'est un bon environnement
pour les animaux oui oui cette forêt
elle est là c'est super parce que ils
peuvent manger tant qu'ils veulent tu es
à côté de l'aéroport ici oui je suis à
côté de l'aéroport non ça gêne pas mais
bon il faut toujours crée la nature même
s'il y a des avions vous voulez qu'on
fasse quoi c'est la vie hein la vie elle
continue bonjour bonjour toi Delphine
bonjour Delphine tu ressembles pas à ma
collègue mais bonjour la première fois
que j'ai vu cette anâne là et C et ces
chèvres là j'étais content de voir ça ça
m'a rappelé mon enfance merci m et vous
c'est comment David David merci am bonne
journée ça m'a touché là en fait ça me
fait plaisir ça me donne la force de
continuer depuis tout petit il a
toujours une passion pour les animaux
mais comme tous les enfants aiment les
animaux qui vont à la ferme on l'EM à la
ferme je pensais que ça allait passer
ben non petit à petit il a eu des
petites fermes dans les jardins de mes
parents de ma sœur de son oncle au vieux
village aussi il a un petit jardin où il
mettait ses animaux après a rencontré
l'association Les qui l'ont repéré et
qui voulaaiit faire un TER d'aventure et
mettre en place une ferme pédagogique il
était très content donc il allait avoir
vraiment sa place son espace V V V V V V
à l'école on m'a il y en a plein qui
croyaient pas en moi à part mes profs et
mon CPE qui demande toujours de mes
nouvelles c'est pareil avec une autre
prof d'horticulture c'était des gens
super des gens qui ne croyaient pas en
toi qu'est-ce qu' te disais tu vas
jamais réussir la vie elle est dure tu
peux pas réussir avec les animaux tu vas
jamais gagner ta vie c'est comme ça
toujours des clichés comme ça c'est un
passe temps il faut trouver un vrai
métier mes parents au début ils étaient
ils étaient pas trop pour au début ils
essayent de m'orienter vers autre chose
mais là maintenant ils ont vu que c'est
c'est pas possible de séparer moi et les
animaux tu as commencé à avoir cette
idée de ferme et tout ça et que les
habitants ici ils ont commencé à voir
les animaux B dans le parking cétait
quoi un peu leur réaction au début
c'était un petit peu dur avec les gens
ils croyaient que c'était juste pour
faire du buzz ils croyaent qu'ils
étaient pas nourris la deuxème semaine
ils ont remarqué ma présence tout ça
c'est devenu une habitude tu as eu des
retours plutôt positifs ils sont tous
positifs mes retours par exemple les
gens ça les apaèise ils sont super
contents d'avoir ça que des voitures
brûlées en bas de chez eux et ça a fait
une vie dans le quartier en fait là
regardez les chèvres qui se promènent là
avec moi voilà caramel caramel bah aller
le chercher il doit être sur le champ
des possible hein où sur le champ des
possible caramel il est malade je pense
attendez
caramel non il a tellement mangé qu'il
est gonflé et son occupe très bien aussi
il est toujours là pour ses animaux et
il est très très fragile par rapport à
ça parfois quand ils ont un souci ou
quoi que soit il va rentrer en pleurant
et moi ça me fait mal donc parfois quand
ça va pas il va venir il va les voir et
puis même lui ça va l'apaiser il y a eu
beaucoup de moterie et aussi qui disait
qu'il était bizarre on me l'a déjà dit à
la figure aussi mais il a persévéré il a
persévéré il a continué il a pas écouter
les mqueries il est beau TR c'est
pistache ah c'est pistache pistache et
lui lui c'est Oreo les gens me
connaissent très bien ils sont super
contents que je passe par là ils me
demandent même que je ramène les chèvres
pour des broussailler là parfois il
m'appelle je les laisse 3 jours ils ont
des enclos vers bleu bas et voilà en
fait moi je suis un lycéen un berger
lycéen je suis au lycée je vais tous les
jours de 8h à entre 8h et 16h 17h je
suis au lycée bonsoir ça va oui ça va je
suis en service Civic aussi en fait en
service civique c'est quand une
association t'embauche pour que ben tu
travailles 24 heur tu t'occupe de un peu
de la vie associative tout ça moi je
m'occupe de la vie du quartier et quand
je dis la vie du quartier c'est avec les
animaux en fait je donne une vie avec
les animaux quand je les sors quand je
fais des balades tout ça V
V bonjour tu as le droit légalement de
te balader avec les animaux pour moi la
terre ça appartient à tout le monde donc
voilà après je su je suis responsable de
mes animaux donc voilà chacun ses
responsabilités mais les animaux
connaissent les voitures ils connaissent
les routes il connaissent tous mes votes
mes animaux moi moi j'ai confiance en
eux et eux ils ont confiance en moi
c'est pour ça on a ce feeling c'est quoi
ton rêve à toi moi mon rêve j'en ai
plein des rêves plus tard moi j'aimerais
avoir une entreprise d'écopâurage
d'animation et de paysage et deslages
donc un peu travaill avec la nature et
les animaux tu es fier de toi ou pas je
suis super fier de rencontrer des gens
comme toi des gens comme on a vu sur la
route qui sont arrêtés pour voir les
animaux parce qu'ils sont contents parce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils voyent pas ça
partout les gens ont oublié ça tellement
ils ont des problème Paris c'est le
stress l'île-defance c'est le stress
plutôt on peut trouver des coins
tranquilles mais en fait il faut un peu
s'éloigner au bout d'un moment le stress
ça joue sur les enjeux de la santé aussi
moi j'ai appris tout ça en fait sur des
reportages j'ai appris tout ça en fait
sur le terrain et j'ai appris tout ça
quand je dis sur le terrain c'était en
découvrant être avec les animaux tout ça
et grâce à des vétérinaires et des
agriculteurs ce qu'on a autour de nous
c'est c'est c'est c'est très très
important où on marche il faut pas
trahir la terre où on marche en fait
parce que beaucoup de gens jettent tout
c'est ça c'est c'est c'est c'est notre
vie cette terre là c'est notre vie s'il
y a pas ça on vit
pas ton rêve le plus cher c'est quoi je
voudrais être sur un autre terrain plus
grand ou plus petit ça me dérange pas
moi je pourrais sortir mes animaux mais
un terrain clôturé un terrain à toi oui
un terrain à moi je serai super
cont